all right so here's the deal okay I
apologize for masturbating the car
that's wrong and you did another thing
for me that was helpful
whereas people don't know about this but
when Ken had his meltdown mm-hmm at
Cobbs where he physically assaulted me
no he never physically assaulted this
what happened so I'm sure you did you
tell yourself did you well first of all
what did you not get in between us this
is what happened okay okay okay so I
think that what happened is that when
the Kim's fractured we I think we had
like an opportunity to really kind of do
some stuff how long were you guys on the
road for it together over the course of
like maybe a year yeah but only that
it's like listen it was a concept that
now would work I think that if we would
never do it but I'm just saying that if
you I Steve that's the producer you burn
ken Jeong that's it us three people that
have no television right or did do it
okay we would draw and it would be great
right back then we did just didn't ken
wasn't the ken Jeong that we know of
today you've done so much stuff since
then yeah I think that you know you
would be great now yeah you know it'll
never happen yeah well I think if you do
it without me with Ken and with Pam
wooden I'm just saying if you do if I
see a [ __ ] billboard no I wouldn't
are you it is if worth right we were to
get [ __ ] weave it out of it you want
another war friend we'll have another
[Laughter]
war well the the Kim's kind of like
imploded pretty quickly because at the
time you were work you're still with
Abby correct yeah okay so we did a new
year easy with her no no III get it
she's not supportive of you yeah and
she's a great representative which is
what you want okay you want somebody
that's in your corner can looks out for
slowly for you we did a show together
collectively yeah for New Year's I
forget where that was we did a New
Year's show and I think you got paid
something like 10 grand and then me Ken
and Bobby me Ken and Kevin each got I
think over the course the week and we
each got like 300 bucks we're like what
the [ __ ] we thought there was gonna be
some disparity of like of like wealth
but we know Bobby's the headliner but we
thought that was so this do you think
the Vice did you think that this
provides thank you thank you I can tell
you done this before so this provides
the beginning of like where I think Ken
and myself felt like a little you know
we're a little bummed by this right so
then we did the the will the will turn
together and it was something along the
same lines where you were getting a line
share and granted given Bobby's cash and
resume he deserves a lion's share but I
think the disparity and pay was so much
that it was like it was kind of like
insulting so I think that's where Ken
took it you know to be you know as Ken
started like ascending to Heights like
he stood at that time right he was on
the P had already done on like the
office and curb curb you know that kind
of stuff but you know starting to do
stuff he was he was in that a couple of
uh
with Will Ferrell movies yeah yeah yeah
yeah he was coming off yeah yeah so he
was like deserving as something but I
think that then you know ken is a very
prideful guy and he I think that you two
had some perhaps like I don't know if
it's like a rivalry but I think that
there was like a I don't know I don't
know what I'd classify it as but
basically it came to a point where it
was just like I think Ken was like
respectively saying I don't know that I
necessarily want to continue with the
cams and I think we all kind of felt
that way at a certain point you know
where it was just like alright well we
ran its course and it was always doing
well in San Francisco but maybe not
anywhere else right fun Hawaii we did a
Hawaii Hawaii was great and so then we
go to San Francisco
and we put together the show me Ken and
Kevin and you weren't on the bill they
didn't want me on it
well yeah out of the group let's be
honest
give you something something right I got
kicked out of the group I think the
three of us collectively can I be honest
what you want me to be completely honest
that's what I want this podcast we
collectively agreed that we were like
given the way we were treated the last
few shows especially in terms of pay we
felt well [ __ ] it let's just do it on
our own
that's what we thought because kick
thattagirl so but what I did is because
as we booked it and as we're getting
closer to date
I just felt guilty and I was like if
we're doing this we should have Bobbi
along and I staged a coup you did I
staged a coup on my own because I love
Ken and I love Bobby and I know that ken
loves Bobby and I know that Bobby loves
Ken and I think we all collectively
internally whether we admit it or not
depending on the precipice of how you
feel at the time everybody feels that
way so I was going with the guise of I'm
gonna fly Bobby up there I bought you a
ticket got your room and I flew you up
there so that we could make peace and
proceed forward from that I think Ken
had a lot going on personally at the
time I think we all know and I think
what happened was you showed up and I
think you stoked some emotions that
weren't resolved and they know what -
I'll tell you what the the the light was
okay fuse was there right but me
lighting it you lit it oh I know and
exactly tell you it was about my space
so what happened was I'll tell you why
my species you were around my space you
could have your arm talking for hop
friends okay right so so for a year or
two years me Steve Byrne were all in his
top and he was still on my top 10 or 15
or whatever it was right but then all of
a sudden his top was Judd Apatow
Will Ferrell all his new fancy friends
so I just wanted to break his balls and
go hey dude what's up
and I said I came up heat from behind
him I remember
it was sitting it with his guitar in the
green room upstairs right yeah and I
came aggressive and which I shouldn't
have done it
yeah but I went what's up dude I'm off
for Utah friends new Hollywood friend
came out hot I came out high really and
he would have complete a versatile thing
why I got the ticket right exactly
I [ __ ] it up right yeah and then it
something happened where it he got in my
face and it was hostile though remember
what he said you came out hot and he
wasn't prepared to have that
conversation he didn't know so I didn't
know I was gonna be there I don't blame
him for really good well I think that
had you come out instead of like the
[ __ ] top eight [ __ ] and just come out
and go hey can we all have a cover song
yeah yeah yeah I said I read it wrong
[ __ ] probably all whites your [ __ ]
six and I'm not even in yeah so then you
guys were screaming at each other
there's a line of people outside and it
looked like you guys were gonna start
fighting and Kevin Shea goes dude you
should go break this up and I looked at
him and I said this might be the cutest
fight I've ever seen in my life if ken
Jeong and Bobby Lee started wrestling
but I broke it up and then uh and then I
think you guys resolved your issues down
a liar years later but I ain't no in
talking to Ken and I don't like to voice
anything I know you know I don't like to
talk publicly about conversations I've
had with my friends personally but I do
know this for a fact I do know that hit
that you absolutely he's expressed this
to me many times that you have helped
him out early on in his career putting
him in all those sketches unmad all
those years ago and I know that he does
love and care about you as do i I mean I
you know no matter what our ups and
downs are I still have a deep affinity
and affection for you because when I
first moved to LA you were literally I
think the first comic I hung out with at
Dublin's and met you and every time I
was there you were always so
accommodating and helpful and so kind of
mean we'd go out for late-night bites
and everything so what's your next door
you want to [ __ ] on me about no because
um you know now when you're talking it
brings me back to um you know
experiences and moments I've had you
know with you know guys like you've been
around for very long my friend prefer so
long and we've been in business together
and we had our ups and downs but you
know at the end of the day even though
there are if I look back in the past
even the things that you've said today I
mean I agree with it yeah for the most
part there's some things I could argue
right but I'm not gonna but because I
cuz that's coming from your point of
view and also I have no hard feelings I
really at the end of the day don't have
any art I don't have any heart I love
you so much right and I do too and in
every like incidents where you've had
battles with like getting cook and stuff
like that I've been on your side but
I've never had battled like a battle at
day like gain picked that issue with me
I know I never I know he did which I've
he did our podcast we talked about never
talked about it
right no he was here I defended you
[Laughter]
[Music]